what's with the jeans so low all I
pulled this up because this guy has the
same name as our son now I was sent this
I like that the video is called oh this
is no this is the wrong thing actually
this is the remix it's gonna be a good
one
there's already lean legs so this is
Ellis Lang sister a few I guess is a few
years ago at a postgame press conference
and he's tripping out man that's I don't
know why that makes me laugh but
happening what happened there you think
I things nervous I think I think he's
nervous you know like these guys are not
public speakers he's an athlete true and
I actually support that 100% that idea
yeah that you you know if somebody
underwhelmed you at their communication
skills and their job is something else
it's not you Jack it's not it's not your
job sweetie yeah it's really not it's
not but they should but that being said
the other guys on the team know like hey
Ellis not so good on the mic so maybe we
should maybe we shouldn't let this guy
talk for the team every one of these
teams by the way has a PR person they
know everybody's strengths they know
everything they know that Ellis on the
mic is going to be a problem
like if bra bra everyone may put Ellis
in front of my won't talk some shit it's
gonna go down okay Ellis man you like
like it like it will you like if you put
my god if you put other songs a mic like
oh it's gonna go poorly man I worked
with a guy that had that same thing with
low tech he'd be like like a look like
it look a little like Cristina you won't
be like lately like upload a look-alike
do you think that this is a tick is that
what it is yeah yeah it's some kind of
nervous tic sure
it's like saying like we say in
California I got a problem with like I
got a problem like tool you know I would
say not to everybody filming I have a
like problem but nothing like his like
own problem Lego like like like like I'm
like I'm like I'm like so do you think
would this constitute us making fun of
somebody with a problem like that you
were talking he's not touched I don't
think he's special
no no I think he's nervous and he
doesn't know what the fuck to say yeah
it happens yeah okay you know Mike's on
him is do you think this guy has a
problem that's cuz our URL like guys are
that's alright well it here's our now
that guy but he has something going on
but then yeah Ellis like like like
like I'm just on like I was just reading
right I was on there I read it on my
mantle and I yeah I'm through the
bollocks are on my man about me maybe
Alan shouldn't speak things I picked it
out there okay yes maybe he just do yes
and no answers correct he's nailed that
twice right on the pot on the positive
side Ellis you can answer yes and no
pretty you say yes sir
just all the other words aren't really
working I just remember too we also
found auntie Fifi remember her yeah yeah
and angels fellatio secrets yeah we
brought her do angels ours
auntie Fifi was she sings there's two
there's auntie fee I think who does the
baking we're doing my own Fifi for you
who's the religious lady from Texas
seeing things that don't even always
either yeah we haven't checked him with
her lily and I've looked on her Facebook
I didn't see any new video so she may
have stopped doing the music things like
today I was thinking oh yeah she's uh
she's great
um but this one yeah let's see if he can
do the second question Christ
that's so funny tripping it they're just
dismissing that like they're praying
stuff in his home
ripped him up what do you think sends
him into the spiral its just wanting to
you know where is it here just wanting
to people saying what's the sound like
he knows what he's saying knows that
he's in front of people and is nervous
about it and then his like yeah he's
like like like like
from like on recording you better get
your life LS like don't put us on that
monster he's got like a Western some
Western European yeah it probably is
he's probably Austrian a Dutch yeah yeah